¿Como construir una bicicleta de montaña para los brazos
que no tenga su coste ni complejidad?
Como sucede con las soluciones simples,
a menudo la respuesta es evidente y para nosotros fue la palanca.
Usamos palancas continuamente, en herramientas, pomos, y piezas de bicicleta.
El momento de inspiración, el momento clave de la creación
fue sentado frente a mi cuaderno de diseño
cuando comencé a pensar sobre alguien sujetando una palanca.
Si se sostiene cerca del final de la misma
se obtiene una palanca de gran longitud
que produce un gran torque según se impulsa de un lado a otro,
obteniendo una marcha corta.
A medida que se desliza la mano hacia abajo,
se impulsa con una longitud de palanca eficaz más pequeña,
pero a través de un angulo mayor, cada impulso
crea una mayor velocidad de rotación y proporciona una marcha más larga.
Lo emocionante de este sistema
radica en que es mecánicamente muy simple
y puedes hacerlo utilizando tecnologia
mundialmente utilizada desde hace cientos de años.
Poniendo esto en practica,
esta es la silla de ruedas "LFC" que
después de algunos años de desarrollo,
está ahora en producción.
Aqui tienen a un usuario de silla de ruedas,
quien sufre de parálisis, en Guatemala,
Pueden ver que puede desplazarse por un terreno escabroso.
La clave, de nuevo, es que cuando él quiere ir deprisa,
sujeta las palancas cerca del eje y utiliza más angulo con cada movimiento
y cuando el movimiento se hace mas complicado, solo tiene que deslizar la manos hacia arriba
creando un mayor par de fuerza, y disminuyendo la fuerza necesaria
para conseguir atravesar el terreno mas difícil.
Lo más importante aquí es que
la persona es la maquinaria compleja en este sistema.
Es la persona la que sube y baja las manos en las palancas
por lo que el propio mecanismo es muy simple
y puede realizarse con piezas de bicicleta accesibles en cualquier lugar del mundo.
Debido a que esas piezas
están ampliamente disponibles, son super baratas.
Son producidas en ingentes cantidades en China e India
y tenemos acceso a ellas en cualquier lugar del mundo,
por lo que podemos construir y reparar la silla en cualquier lugar
incluso en un pequeño pueblo con el mecánico local,
ya que tiene las herramientas, el conocimiento y las piezas disponibles.
Cuando se quiere utilizar la silla LFC en interiores,
todo lo que hay que hacer es quitar las palancas del tren motriz,
guardarlas en los laterales, y se convierte en una silla de ruedas normal
que puedes utilizar como cualquier otra,
ya que el tamaño es el mismo.
Es lo suficientemente estrecha como para atravesar una puerta de tamaño normal,
es lo suficientemente baja para encajar debajo de una mesa
y es pequeña para que resulte manejable en el baño
para que el usuario pueda acercarse al inodoro
y sea capaz de sentarse en el
como haría con una silla de ruedas convencional.
Hay tres puntos en los que me gustaría hacer incapie
ya que creo que son la base de este proyecto.
El primero es que el producto es viable porque
hemos sido capaces de combinar eficazmente
rigurosa ingeniería y análisis con un diseño centrado en el usuario
teniendo en cuenta los factores sociales y económicos,
tan importantes para los usuarios de sillas de ruedas en los países en vías de desarrollo.
Como académico en el Instituto Tecnologico de Massachussets e ingeniero mecanico
puedo hacer cosas como ver en qué tipo de terreno por el que hay que desplazarse,
averiguar cuanta resistencia ofrecerá,
ver que piezas hay disponibles, mezclarlas y juntarlas
para averiguar que tipo de tren de engranaje se puede utilizar,
y después ver la potencia y la fuerza que se puede obtener del tren superior de nuestro cuerpo,
para analizar a qué velocidad podremos desplazarnos en esta silla
moviendo las manos a lo largo de las palancas.
A si que, como un estudiante entusiasmado
nuestro equipo creó un prototipo
que llevamos a Tanzania, Kenia y Vietnam en el 2008,
para descubrir que era pésimo;
porque no tuvimos suficiente información de los usuarios.
Así que lo probamos con usuarios de sillas de ruedas,
con fabricantes que nos dieron su opinión,
no solo expresando sus problemas, sino también exponiendo sus soluciones
y trabajando conjuntamente volvimos a la mesa de diseño y creamos un nuevo modelo
con el que volvimos a África del este en 2009.
Resultó funcionar mucho mejor en terreno escabroso que una silla de ruedas convencional
aunque todavía no funcionaba bien en interiores ya que era demasiado grande
y pesado, difícil de maniobrar.
De nuevo, con la opinión de los usuarios, volvimos a la mesa de trabajo
y conseguimos un mejor diseño, 9 kilos más ligero,
y tan estrecho como una silla de ruedas convencional. Lo probamos en Guatemala
y la mejora fue tal que nos llevo
, donde estamos ahora, a su producción.
Además de ser ingenieros
hemos sido capaces de cuantificar los beneficios de rendimiento de nuestra silla LFC.
Aquí tienen algunos datos de nuestras pruebas en Guatemala,
doinde probamos nuestra LFC en el terreno del pueblo,
y recogimos los resultados biomecánicos de los usuarios,
su consumo de oxigeno, lo rápido que se desplazan,
y cuanta energía emplean en ello, tanto
con nuestra silla LFC como con una convencional,
y descubrimos que nuestra silla es un 80% más rapida
en estos terrenos que una silla tradicional.
También es un 40% más eficiente y debido
a la ventaja mecánica que se obtiene de las palancas
produce un 50% de incremento en el par motor
y supone una ayuda real en terreno escabroso.
La segunda lección que hemos aprendido es que
las limitaciones en el diseño realmente impulsan la innovación.
Debido a que teníamos que alcanzar un coste realmente bajo,
conseguir que la silla pudiera ser útil en diferentes tipos
de terreno a la vez que en interiores
y ser lo suficientemente simple para repararla
acabamos consiguiendo un producto en esencia nuevo,
una innovación
en un sector que no ha cambiado en cientos de años.
Las ventajas que supone no son sólo aplicables a los países en vías de desarrollo.
¿Por que no también en países como E.E. U.U.?
Para ello nos asociamos con Continuum,
una empresa de diseño local en Boston
para realizar la versión de gama alta apropiada para los países desarrollados,
cuyo mercado seria principalmente Estado Unidos y Europa
enfocado a compradores de ingresos altos.
El último punto que me gustaría resaltar es mi convicción
de que este proyecto ha resultado exitoso porque hemos involucrado
a todos los inversionistas que han creído en él; que han sido valiosos
para desarrollar la tecnología desde la creación de una idea
a través de la innovación, validación, comercialización y difusión
sabiendo que ese ciclo comienza y termina en los usuarios.
Ellos son quienes definen los requisitos tecnológicos
y quienes tienen que darnos finalmente el visto bueno
diciendo: "Si, efectivamente funciona. Cubre nuestras necesidades".
Así, personas como yo en el ámbito académico
podemos innovar, analizar y probar,
procesar datos y realizar prototipos a nivel experimental.
¿Pero como conseguimos comercializar esos prototipos?
Para ello necesitamos expertos en comercialización, como Continuum,
lo que nos llevo a crear una ONG para llevar nuestra silla al mercado
"Investigación Global de Innovación Tecnológica"
y también a asociarnos con un gran fabricante en la India, Industrias Pinnacle,
esto nos ha dado capacidad para producir 500 sillas al mes.
El primer lote de 200 estará disponible el próximo mes
para su envío a la India.
Finalmente para acercarnos a la gente a gran escala,
nos asociamos con la mayor organización de discapacidad
del mundo, "Jaipur Foot".
Lo más valioso de este modelo
es el poder juntar a todas la partes interesadas
que representan a todos los eslabones de la cadena
desde la concepción de la idea
hasta la implementación en el campo.
Ahí es donde sucede la magia.
Ahí es donde una persona como yo, un academico
puede analizar, probar y crear nueva tecnología
y determinar cuantitativamente su rendimiento.
Puedes conectar con inversionistas, como los fabricantes,
hablar directamente con ellos y hacer uso de su
conocimiento en las practicas de fabricación locales y sus clientes;
y combinar esas aportaciones con nuestro conocimiento de ingenieria,
para crear conjuntamente algo mejor que lo que cualquiera de nosotros podría haber hecho por separado.
Así puedes Involucrar también al usuario final
en el proceso de diseño, no solo preguntando por sus necesidades,
sino preguntándole cómo piensa que pueden conseguirse.
Esta es una foto de nuestra ultima prueba de campo en la India,
donde tuvimos una tasa de adopción del 90%, que prefirieron
el uso de nuestra silla sobre el de una convencional,
y esta foto en concreto es de Ashok,
que sufre una lesión espinal por una caída de un árbol.
Él es sastre, pero desde que sufrió el accidente
no ha sido capaz de realizar el trayecto de un kilómetro
desde su casa a su tienda en silla de ruedas porque
el camino es muy escabroso.
Pero el día después de tener nuestra silla,
pudo desplazarse ese kilómetro y abrir su tienda,
poco después consiguió un contrato para hacer los uniformes del colegio
y comenzó a ganar dinero, y pudo mantener a su familia de nuevo.
Ashok: "Tu también me animaste a trabajar.
Descansé un día en casa y
al día siguiente volví a mi tienda.
Ahora todo ha vuelto a la normalidad."
Amos Winter: Muchas gracias por invitarme hoy.